[موسيقى]
يعني اهم شيء في الموضوع يا دكتوره الان
لما نشوف الحجر الحجر يحتاج قص صحيح صحيح
قديما لما كان الوضع الاقتصادي ليس جيد هو
الحجر موجود بكل مكان لكنه متعب اكثر
الطين اسهل صحيح صحيح يعني هنا
التنور هنا نجد ايضا هذا كنموذج التنور
شوفوا الان نحفر التنور القديم شوف نجد
التنور هذا موجود شوف الرماد نعم هذا
الرماد القديم الذي يستخدم لايضا لاعداد
الطعام ووضع ايضا البر فيه وايضا استخدام
الاكل هذه نموذج من النماذج القديمه
الموجوده في كل منزل من منازل حجر اليمامه
القديمه تقدم لك هذا التصور وايضا هذه
الفكره في قضيه تصميم البيوت الموجوده في
حجر اليمامه اذا قصور
القصور القديمه من ايام طسم
وجديس والتي بقيت كانت مبنيه من الحجر
والليله
القرن الرابع الهجري صحيح مبنيه من الحجر
وزاد البناء والاتساع في وجود الاستقرار
الحضري لقبيله بني حنيفه بني حنيفه
الاتصال ايضا الحضاري وعمق الوادي ادى الى
اتساع ايضا ونماء البلدات المحيطه بهذا
الوادي من ضمن هذه البلدات ما نحن الان
موجودين فيه كنموذج ونرى الان زي ما تشوف
كثره الفخار صحيح صحيح وجذع شجره متحجر
ترى هذا مهم جدا هذا جذع الشجره المتحجر
معناته انه في مدينه كبيره مدفونه تحتاج
تنقيه اكذلك هذا النموذج الان الموجودين
فيه هنا النموذج ايضا الاماكن الاخرى
المجاوره لهذا ربما سيتم له الحفريات فيها
وجدنا اعظم من هذه باضعاف اضعاف وهذه
الحقيقه لابد ان تتجه لها الجهات ايضا
مختصه والمهتمه ايضا في التنقيب والاثار
في الجامعات او الجهات العلميه او الجهات
الحكوميه لابد الحقيقه ان ينقبون ايضا
والمزيد من الاكتشافات الحقيقه تخرج علينا
اضعاف اضعاف وتقدم لنا نموذج كما ذكرنا
الموجوده ايضا في مدينه حجر اليمامه اذا
الرياض حجر اليمامه قديما وما حولها من
بلدات التنقيب الاثري لانه تعرف مر علينا
فتره ما كان في ربما هذه الاثاره اكثر
تدمره صحيح صحيح سواء في الرياض او غير
الرياح صحيح لكن الرياض تاريخها في
التاريخ صحيح يعني شوف كثره المدققات
الادوات الحجريه شيء عجيب الزجاج نجده في
هذه المنطقه ايضا استيراد الزجاج من خارج
الجزيره العربيه نجد نماذج لهذا الزجاج
لان القوافل اذا اتت حجر اليمامه من اهم
محطات درب البخور الفين سنه قبل الميلاد
في ناس يقولون اقل في ناس يقولون لكن مع
تسجيل الجمل وما ذكرناه سابقا من ادله
انها من الاف السنين قبل الميلاد صحيح منذ
تجين الجمل وهي محطه من درب التجاره